hey so here I am with another exam
unboxing video on all of my previous
exam videos I was met with some comments
from Indian viewers who would say this
is too easy compared to the exams we do
here in India and specifically people
mentioned the je e advanced paper as
being a much tougher exam than the
American European and Australian ones
that I was covering so thanks to those
comments
today I am coming after the je e
advanced paper now this is the 2006 copy
I'll link it down in the description
along with the solutions because all of
these pass papers are actually available
online this is a paper that would be set
by high school students trying to get
into some of India's engineering
colleges and it stands for the Joint
Entrance Examination so it's a bit of a
beast of a paper it's pretty thick and
it covers physics chemistry and
mathematics and just taking a quick
glance at it from here it seems to
really cover you know all the
fundamentals of those three disciplines
and you know wants to test you on what
would be the basis of knowledge to go on
and study engineering I'm going to have
a look through some of the questions and
just see if it lives up to the hype from
people who have been commenting on my
channel and I'm also at the end of this
video going to compare it to this paper
which is a physics exam from New Zealand
and it's what high school students there
would sit if they wanted to go on and do
engineering at university so I'll see
sort of how the Indian standard compares
to what I would consider standard for
high school students in Australia and
New Zealand also for my next video I'd
like to fully work through the solution
to one of the J EE advanced questions so
if there's a particular question you'd
like me to do for that next video leave
it down in the comment and without any
further delay let's have a look at the
paper alright here we are so the first
thing that strikes me is that well
everything is multiple choice
so the exams got that going for it and
then there's the marking scheme so it
looks like we get three marks for a
correct answer zero if we don't attend
and minus one marks if we get it wrong
now that is really harsh and you know it
sounds like that way you get negative
marks are really discouraging from just
you know trying to have a guess but it's
also very discouraging and very
nerve-racking because you're always
doubting yourself because there's so
much at stake you don't want to get the
answer wrong so let's have a look I
think we're starting off with some quite
easy questions as the physics section
and this first question here looks like
it's just got to do with the
photoelectric effect and really that
would be as simple as just plugging some
of these numbers into one formula so
easy so far we have sort of similar type
questions I think this question here is
another just one formula than it you'll
need to know relating to the specific
heat of water and then another pretty
easy question here about a guess Snell's
law and the reflection of light we've
got a question here about an infinite
line of charge this in particular is not
something that I did at high school but
instead at first-year University Physics
learning how to do things like Gauss's
law and finding out you know the
distribution of charge along different
shaped objects so this if you're having
to derive the laws from scratch is a
little bit more advanced than I would
have seen at school moving on to
question two now and it looks like
things are getting even more high-stakes
negative marks are minus two for all
wrong answers so yeah probably be
sweating by this point we've got some
questions about nuclear physics
soundwaves lenses and radiation and even
some thermodynamics we've got a
conceptual question about some
electromagnetism and even some vector
calculus then we've got section three on
the physics section and it changes a
little bit here instead of being
multiple choice it looks like there's a
single digit integer for each answer can
some of these are a little bit more
involved I do sort of feel that by the
end of this physics section we've
covered material that yes I definitely
learned at my first-year University
course I think from my experience with
Australia in New Zealand this depth of
physics isn't necessarily taught at high
school but it's because it doesn't have
to be I think the issue is that
engineering in India is such a
competitive field or to get into the
colleges are so competitive that you
really need to be at the top of your
game and studying for exams like this je
e to get a spot I guess in Australia in
New Zealand I felt a little bit luckier
and that we do I feel end up learning
the same content but it comes at a
little bit of a later stage because
getting into university itself is not so
competitive the real work can really
start once you get there rather than
before you walk in the door we're moving
on to chemistry here which I personally
haven't done since high school but it
looks like a bit of a similar thing
we've got some negative marks for wrong
answers a few sort of questions where I
guess if you've practiced this kind of
thing and you know the formulas and you
know how to work through some of these
easier questions this should be okay but
you know this section and even the
physics section I I do have a physics
degree but I'd need to do some study to
be able to pass this because it really
focuses on the details and a very broad
range of details details that you would
only remember if you are trying to
remember them for something like an exam
I think one of the hardest things about
this exam just by looking at it was the
sheer quantity of information it is so
broad it covers so many different areas
and you looks like you're having to do
it all at once so for in that reason
this does look like a very I guess
taxing exam it does look difficult I'll
give it that like I'm not going to say
this is an easy
and especially for high school students
it's you know if you're passing this and
getting a good grade on this that's
really quite impressive so here's the
mathematics section it looks like the
mathematics section is pretty strong and
you know pretty difficult I would say
that the notation and the type of
questions is more something I would
expect to see at an Australian
University course rather than testing
high school students to get in with that
being said I feel that in mathematics
difficulty is relative to what you've
been exposed to sometimes questions are
not inherently harder than other
questions it just depends on what water
you've been learning them in and what
content you've been focusing on in class
so it's really hard to compare that
relative difficulty because I can only
assume that this is what's being taught
in a school in India for students who
are wanting to sit this exam but I know
it probably also does take a lot of
self-study as well there's a lot of
material in this exam we do have a bit
of mathematical analysis as well which
is impressive to see and getting into
linear algebra and matrices those were
something that I personally again didn't
see until the University but it depends
on the order you're learning them in how
difficult they'll be to you we've got
what looks like a quite advanced
geometry problem
something about a differential equation
so that was the last page and and let's
just have a little comparison with the
New Zealand physics paper for high
school students who would be graduating
and going on to university the New
Zealand papers are separated up into
lots of different modules so this paper
here only deals with electrical systems
so this is really just to show you how
it's going to look different in New
Zealand exams often it's not multiple
choice but short answers and long
answers focusing more on explaining
questions and actually using your
communication skills and English and
writing rather than just doing the pure
calculation for this Christian there is
one set up with several questions that
follow on from it
this is a difference to the Indian exam
where everything is much more segmented
and there are just lots of individual
questions which are not really related
to each other so overall I think that
studying for this je II advanced paper
will take a lot of time that's because
it is so broad and there are so many
questions that you need to know how to
do and do well because you don't want to
lose marks I think that doing well on an
exam like this is going to take a lot of
practice a lot of practice not just
remembering formula about how to use
them and actually how to think and
adjust to the way that the questions
will differ slightly from whatever the
practice material is so if you have done
this exam you've done well on it or even
just attempted it I'd say well done to
you because it definitely would take a
lot of study I'm not really a fan of
saying that one country's exams are
harder than any others because I think
it's sort of relative and it kind of
evens out in the end
you might learn more stuff up front but
what matters in the end is understanding
of some of these engineering concepts
and the ability to go on to use them in
creative ways to do great work in the
world so I hope that was a good insight
into this exam and like I said I will do
a full work through of one of the
questions in my next video so if there's
a question that you'd really like me to
do just leave it as a comment thanks for
watching and I'll see you next time